Hawaii official reportedly delayed
releasing water critical to battling the
devastating wild wildfires President Joe
Biden and the first lady set to be in
Maui today to visit the devastation from
wildfires there firsthand as the number
of fatalities grow in Hawaii so do the
questions like how something like this
could happen in the first place as the
fires rage on the Hawaiian island of
Maui this is what one of the locals have
to say okay I gotta tell you guys I am
so frustrated with investors and
Realtors calling the families who lost
their home offering to buy their land
how dare you do that to our community
right now this is some pilau Heaven that
happening right now I am so frustrated
hearing since yesterday that multiple
families that I know personally were
reached out and offered money from
investors and Realtors shame on you
there's a lot of real estate speculation
happening right now that is really
frustrating and I just want to remind
all you Real Estate Investors around the
world like Lahaina is not for sale
please don't reach out to these families
and take advantage of them during the
most devastating Time Of Our Lives the
fire started on August 8 2023 and it's
been one of the worst disasters to hit
the island in modern history at least
114 people are dead with another 850
still missing
foreign
is far more than just a natural disaster
gone wrong cly has always been a
contentious U.S states stolen from the
native Hawaiians Hawaii has always had a
lot of tension between the natives and
the Americans and this story is no
different see Maui is home to many
powerful names Jeff Bezos owns a 78
million home on Maui Larry Ellison of
Oracle owns 98 of the island of Lanai
Oprah owns land on Maui near the fires
and many many more and yet you've barely
heard a peep out of any of these people
the story of the Hawaii fires is a story
of cover-up's corporate greed terrible
mismanagements vultures trying to swoop
in and buy up all this burnt up real
estate for pennies on the dollar and
maybe even arson stay dangerous and this
is why they want Hawaii to burn
[Music]
you want to know what's harder than
buying a holiday home in Hawaii keeping
track of all the recurring subscriptions
you pay for which is why I use today's
sponsor rocket money rocket money is an
all-in-one Finance platform that helps
you save more and spend less this
personal finance app allows you to
manage subscriptions lower bills build a
custom budget and grow your savings all
in one place for me I love using rocket
money to view all the subscriptions I
have in one place so I can cancel the
ones I no longer need my other favorite
feature is that you can upload or
connect your bills and their negotiators
will go to work to lower your bills for
you to save more and spend less join the
3.4 million members using rocket money
today I've got the hookup go to
rocketmoney.com check or click the link
below to get started for free you can
also unlock even more features with
premium that's rocketmoney.com Jake to
get started for free
on the afternoon of August 8 2023 a fire
started near the town of Lahaina in Maui
fueled by dry grass and Powerful gusts
of winds caused by Hurricane Dora and
the fire quickly spread within less than
15 minutes it had reached the town
leaving nothing but destruction in this
wake people ran for their lives some
even dove into the ocean to escape the
Flames thousands of houses were burned
to the ground and more than a hundred
people died for weeks before the fire
started the island had been very hot and
dry with grass soil and trees drying up
it was the perfect conditions for a fire
everyone had been told to be extra
careful and to avoid anything that could
start a fire so if the whole island was
on alert then the number one question on
everyone's mind is who started it who
was responsible for one of the most
devastating wildfires in U.S history
according to official sources no cause
has been found yet but that's not really
true because one company seems to be
trying to play Down how big of a role
they played in the fires August 7th at
10 47 PM a day earlier you hear a
witness describe a flash that might be a
three falling on a power line it's windy
and then there's a Flash and I think
that's when a tree is falling on a power
line the power goes out one expert
saying those videos take in an up
country Maui show the Flames spreading
and maybe the first evidence of downed
power lines igniting a fire
oh this is live right across the street
from my house
freaking power line just went down I
hear a pop coming from across the street
as soon as I hear the pop all I heard is
like electrical like this is going on
the ground there and look there's a
power line right there
started
from up the road there and all of that
is still burning in Hawaii less than one
percent of fires start due to natural
causes yes that is right 99 of fires in
Hawaii are caused by humans and the Maui
fires are no different so who did it one
suspect is Hawaiian Electric the biggest
utility company in Maui as far back as
2019 Hawaiian Electric had known about
the danger postbots powerless falling or
emitting Sparks during the dry windy
season old power lines are paralyzed
near trace or one of the biggest risks
during big storms one spark or even just
a falling Branch can set fire to dry
grass in seconds to keep that from
happening Hawaiian Electric would need
to trim all the trees near the power
lines across the islands they would also
have to reinforce their power lens and
poles to resist strong winds the company
estimated that this kind of overhaul of
his power lines would cost at least 190
million dollars money that will probably
have to come out of its own pockets and
if there's anything that big business
hates is spending their hard earned
money on useless stuff like safety
safety isn't going to improve Revenue
it's not gonna boost their profit
emergence so if the people of Maui
wanted to make these improvements so
badly the money will have to come out of
them which meant Hawaiian Electric would
have to raise its electricity rates it
would take Hawaiian Electric three years
to commit to making these improvements
in 2022 it finally asked State
Regulators to allow it to raise rates to
fund the 190 million it needed that
request is still pending to this day
while Maui is burning to the ground you
see Hawaiian Electric knew just how big
of a risk they were taking by putting
off the maintenance they knew they
needed but that is not even where the
bad choices end one of the company's
main safety features is a public power
shutoff plan that lets them turn off all
the electricity during a severe storm
that way if power lines did fall there
would be no way it would cause a fire
but during this storm they never shut
off the electricity according to the
company they didn't want to turn off the
power because electricity was needed to
pump water to fire trucks but you
wouldn't even need water in fire trucks
if there were no fires in the first
place instead the real reason they
didn't want to turn off the power was
because they were afraid of public
backlash they didn't want the bad
publicity or to lose money after all
getting your electricity voluntarily
turned off in the middle of a storm
isn't gonna feel very good you're gonna
be pissed off at that utility company
and so on August 7th and 8th Hawaiian
Electric power lines caused fires in two
different areas near Lahaina August 7th
at 10 47 PM a day early you hear a
witness describe a flash that might be a
tree falling on a power line it's windy
and then there's a Flash and I think
that's when a tree is falling on a power
line the power goes out one expert
saying those videos take in an up
country Maui show the Flames spreading
and maybe the first evidence of downed
power lines igniting a fire oh this is
live right across the street from my
house
freaking power line just went down I
hear a pop coming from across the street
as soon as I hear the pop all I heard is
like electrical like this is going on
the ground there and look there's a
power line right there
started
from up the road there
and all of that is still burning from
there to me it simulated a fuse like
somebody little fuse for a firework
experts say these two fires likely
spread causing the massive wildfire that
destroyed the entire town and within
days of these two videos being shared
Hawaiian Electric shares lost half of
their value and dozens of Maui residents
are now fouling a class action lawsuit
against them for being responsible for
the fire the company had tried counting
Corners when it came to safety and now
it looks like they're going to be paying
a whole lot more than 190 million
dollars anyways and you would think that
a massive company like this trying to
cover up its responsibility for a
wildflower would be the worst Scandal to
come out of all this but you would be
wrong because it gets a whole lot worse
[Applause]
thank you
one of the scariest things about the
Hawaii Wildfire is just how quickly it
spread by one mile every minute once the
fire reaches towns like Lahaina it moves
so quickly that there was little to no
chance anyone could outrun it which is
why so many people ended up in the ocean
to try to escape it meanwhile harrowing
footage has emerged of a group of people
forced to escape into the sea as the
fires erupted all around them on Tuesday
night with the fire spreading so quickly
every single second counts knowing about
the fire a minute earlier could save
dozens of lives unfortunately with the
power lines either failing or setting on
fire a wise emergency text alert system
failed by the time the test came through
telling people to evacuate it was
already too late the fire had reached
the town if only there had been some way
to warn Maui and Lahaina residents of
the approaching Blaze some sort of
warning system that didn't rely on cell
service
except there is an independent warning
system that could have gotten people out
of their homes earlier it was just never
used as an Island state Hawaii has more
than 400 Hazard Sirens all across the
islands the largest Network in the world
according to the Hawaii Emergency
Management agency the sirens are there
to warn people of all sorts of disasters
like tsunamis wildfires flooding and
terrorist attacks 80 of these signs are
located on Maui and many of them are in
or around Lahaina but when it came time
to warn people about the fires the
alarms never went off instead the only
warning people got of impending doom was
a massive cloud of black smoke over the
town but by then it was already too late
for many people
people were Furious weren't the sirens
there for a reason why didn't they use
them if they knew there was a fire
coming what was the point of putting up
all these Sirens If you were never going
to use them it turns out the star is
never being used as all thanks to one
guy Maui emergency management
administrator hermit and Daya according
to him he never approved the sirens
being used because he believed that
people would think it was a tsunami
warning and that they would head to the
mountains which would have been directly
into the fire which sounds reasonable
you have been warning Maui residents of
powerful winds and wildfires for weeks
but when the sirens go off they're
definitely gonna only think that it's
for a tsunami and head directly towards
the black smoke and even if people
thought it was a tsunami warning at
first all it would take was them walking
outside and seeing all the black smoke
in the sky that was the official reason
the Cyrus never went off but over the
next few days a whole lot of other
excuses came out as well some of the
signs were broken and wouldn't work or
some of the signs had never been
activated and wouldn't work at all which
made the entire story very hard to
believe if they really didn't want
people to run towards the fire towards
the mountains why would they be making
all these other excuses as well
something did not feel right but the
icing on the King was the days after the
fire started the stand-up guy Hermann
and Dyer who was in charge of turning
the sirens on decided to resign from
this position due to health reasons so
an electric company starts a massive
fire the people in charge never use the
warning system created specifically for
a situation like that but if you thought
that was the end you were once again
sadly mistaken because as Maui burned to
the ground it didn't take long for big
businesses and investors to see a golden
opportunity
[Music]
the Maui fires had not even been 100
contained when the first solicitations
came through some of the things that's
already been happening is Realtors are
calling families who lost everything
offering them to buy their their
property and their home for pennies on
the dollar so it's pretty offensive to
us that people won't even give us the
time to grieve properly and people's
mental health has been diminished in all
of this they've lost everything people
have lost family members and for them to
have that disrespect to come in and
really try and buy things up is out of
control with thousands of homes being
burnt down it seemed like an easy deal
it was going to take months even years
for these homes to be rebuilt in the
meantime thousands of people had just
lost everything their homes their cars
all their possessions so why not go in
and offer them a few hundred thousand
dollars for land that you know is worth
millions in a situation like this it's
easy to see why people would have no
choice but to sell they have no home
they have no clothes or food they
desperately needed the money from the
people of Maui the fires were a
devastating disaster before investors
and real estate developers it was the
perfect opportunity to make millions all
they would have to do is buy the land
from homeless Hawaiians rebuild luxury
homes and hotels on that land and then
sell it to billionaires and millionaires
looking for a holiday home or a beach
house and they've gone to extremes to
get people to sell quote there are still
bodies being pulled out of water outside
of Maui and you suddenly get a call or a
message on Facebook saying we want to
buy your property End quotes it's gotten
so bad that the governor of Hawaii is
even considering suspending the housing
market to stop people from selling their
land out of desperation so what is the
lesson from this is that one disaster
strikes you gotta be right there
checkbook in hand waiting to submit an
offer on some prime Oceanfront real
estates
[Music]
and you want to know what else is eerily
suspicious how in the span of around
three decades more than 50 people
connected to Bill and Hillary Clinton
have died 50 people and you want to know
what's even more suspicious is that all
50 of these people didn't die from
natural causes oh no each of these 50
people all died in one of the three ways
suicide plane crash or robbery gone
wrong just those three and these are not
just random people no these are people
who all have the power to ruin the
public image of the clintons these are
people that could have linked to cleanse
the scandals and now magically all of
them died and what's even crazier is
that most of these deaths magically came
to an end after Clinton left the White
House and we expose it all in our new
private documentary The Clinton kill
list that you can watch right now by
clicking the join button below this one
is very damning and you are not going to
want to miss it and by the way guys I've
realized that Although our YouTube
membership has been pretty controversial
I don't think it's been controversial
enough so we're really stepping on the
gas and we're only doing private
documentaries from now on that have the
potential for me to be canceled or
suicidal like this one once a month
maybe even more in the future that
you're definitely not going to get
anywhere else we've got a really
exciting one coming out soon on how if a
certain German man with a small mustache
actually off themselves wink wink stay
tuned we've got ones on every Jeff's
theme the CIA is disturbing my control
experiments and many many more so click
the join button below or click the card
on the screen to watch the Clinton kill
list now
foreign
[Music]